oh well my talk of the table is that new
york city is hosting
its largest ticketed dance event since
the pandemic began tonight it's
happening tonight folks
it is the annual dance against cancer
benefit performance
and for dancer kevin bozeman the fight
against cancer
is personal he fought the disease
himself and lost his younger brother
actor and academy award nominee chadwick
to colon cancer last year we went with
kevin to a rehearsal for tonight's event
and saw him meet the kids he'll perform
with tonight
he explained why this event is so
important to him
i had a cancer diagnosis back in 2018
and i am in remission two and a half
years in remission
and then thank you thank you
and i am the older brother of chadwick
boseman the actor who played the black
panther who
passed away also of cancer in august of
last year
so when earl called and asked me to
participate in this dance against cancer
benefit
it felt extremely appropriate for
the journey that i've personally been on
the last few years as well as what my
family has
gone through well kevin wants to
highlight the importance of early
detection and he chooses to keep the
details of his own cancer diagnosis
private he joins us now for his first tv
interview since his brother died we
welcome you kevin so much
thank you thank you for having me thanks
for being here so given the fact that
your family has had cancer as such
a debilitating part of your experience
uh i i can't imagine what this
performance means to you
i really want to know what you were
looking forward to
because it just with those kids i can't
imagine it being any better than that
yeah i got to rehearse with them a few
days ago and
that was my first time seeing that we
keep hearing about them in our
in the rehearsals for the day for the
adult dancers and
seeing them it brought tears to my eyes
actually it really brought tears to my
so i'm excited to
get to dance with them and for the whole
piece and the entire evening to come
together
and and like you said it's the i'm sorry
tony it's the first ticketed
uh dance performance since the pandemic
and so i'm so excited because it means
the world is opening back up yeah it
must feel great just to be back
yeah absolutely i was going to say
you're in remission congratulations
that's wonderful news uh we welcome it
uh why
come forward now to tell your story
about your experience
so when i told my story which was on
instagram
stories i basically had been
in la with my brother for about five
months he called me out
back in march asked me to come help my
parents were there my older brother also
was in and out during that time
so i had actually missed two cancer
screenings myself
and was passed my own uh two-year mark
of knowing whether i was still in
remission
and then we lost him and for me
when i went in for that screening it was
really
i was anxious i was terrified
we had just lost him six weeks before
and
i was it felt like a celebration it was
a moment of celebration because i was
like
we've just lost him we've just gone
through this terrible thing
and it would be terrible for my cancer
to be back for me to have to tell my
family that my cancer is back
for me to have to go into chemotherapy
again
and so i chose to really celebrate it by
sharing it i didn't expect what happened
after i shared it but
yeah so so much of uh who chadwick
was and is is part of his career
but you knew him as chad and he was such
a lovely human being i had the chance to
meet him
after 42 came out and humble
sweet and he's a howard bison yes he is
and he was so proud of that
tell us about the chad you knew chad
was funny he had an incredible sense of
humor
he loved to laugh he loved to sing we
sang together
he was just full of passion he loved
people he loved kids
he loved his family he loved howard he
loved
black people you know yeah he was very
private about what he was going through
obviously because
yeah um and but i'm sure the family knew
what is the grieving process been like
for you
tremendous it's been absolutely
tremendous
um i would say i've gone through
the stages of sadness
i think i've just passed through the
stage of anger yeah
um but it's been tremendous and we've
just all drawn together
yeah we're a close family anyway and i
think we've just become
even closer howard university is going
to name its college of fine arts
after your brother yes how do you feel
about that tribute i think it's
uh an absolutely appropriate tribute and
very excited about that i love the smile
yeah yeah
yeah felicia rashad will be teaching yes
she'll be the dean
who was one of his professors and
mentors while while he was there yeah
unbelievable you're a big advocate of
early detection absolutely so
so give us give us your speech on that
what's your message
i believe that as a cancer survivor
i know that i detected it myself i felt
the lump
i alerted my doctor at a routine
checkup that i had it was and he said
okay let's monitor this
a few months later it was still there
and we began the process so i believe
that
we are our first line of defense and
that also our doctors are our other
first line of defense 22 million
people missed cancer screenings last
year because of covid so it's so
important that people get those cancer
screenings yeah
so important to mention that you brought
it to your doctor's attention
i did there are screenings and your
doctor's here to take a look at things
but we also need to be aware ourselves
absolutely right
kevin thank you very much thank you